ecke zu drängen war student jetzt
bekommen war im neuen video hätte ich
hoffe ich geht es gut
auf jeden fall jetzt mit nein ich meinem
eine zuschauerin hatte ihr seid mir das
scheißegal wer heute auf jeden fall
haben wir heute einmal zu meiner linken
marie das geht alles klar
ja haben nur verlieren und auf meiner
rechten main mitte oder beides menschen
die man ab und zu mal ertragen muss ja
und ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich am titel
schon gelesen und zwar geht es heute um
was man heute genau ich habe mich ja
natürlich ich habe mich nämlich
hingesetzt habe mir ein paar fragen
überlegt für euch beide und ihr müsst
halt möglichst schnell darauf antworten
safe wirst du die dümmsten auf ich bin
mal gespannt welche zehn jahre ist
aneinander ich bin auch gespannt so
leute wir müssen jetzt mal kurz ein
haken und zwar habe ich jetzt im juli
hier dabei und wir sind irgendwann auf
die idee kommen ja das war so eine
challenge treten halt so erkennt mich
besser wir haben allerdings uns gedacht
das gibt's ja schon das ja langweilig
deswegen haben wir uns so etwas überlegt
und zwar einen leichten break es ist
jetzt nicht so der mega projekt aber ich
habe mir noch was pony wird aber schon
traum ist ja natürlich aber ich habe mir
schon überlegt der verlierer wir bauen
das so auch so der verlierer muss in
verschlüsselte orange muss aber auf die
andere seite zumindest mal meister
so sagen wir das und dann sagen wir erst
ganz am ende nein musst du nicht macht
auf jeden fall habe ich halt so acht
fragen rausgesucht oder zehn fragen wie
habe ich julia leischik zukommen
europäisch blöde sache möchte was ist
die lieblingsfarbe von meiner oma rosa
das kann ja eigentlich kein mensch
wissen und das ding seit juli wird euch
wissen
ja soll ich alles richtig genau also
alles richtig wir haben auch als das
rough nein nein wir haben als
einstiegsfrage so 16 tage daran habe ich
geburtstag
ja zum beispiel oder keine haben die
andere frage war irgendwie allen
kontinenten europa weil sowas kann man
eventuell ja wissen also es ist jetzt
nicht so auffällig gestaltet aber ein
paar fragen sind schon extrem blöd also
die kamera nicht gar nicht wissen ihr
werdet das sehen ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß und ja maria schöne durch juri
weiss ich bin mal gespannt wer von euch
beiden gewinnt ich habe mir auch eine
ganz kleine strafe überlegt uns warm war
da hinten so ein paar früchte und da
haben wir nur rumliegen und die
vorrangig ist ein bisschen angeschrieben
aber nur auf einer seite unterstrich
dafür wird man krank und der verlierer
muss einmal ganz kurz auf die andere
seite weiß ist nicht nur meine ich damit
mein teil dann müsst ihr euch anstrengen
jetzt hört hier auch mit dem gemeckere
ja wir kommen jetzt sofort zur ersten
frage und war eigentlich ganz einfach da
bin ich mal gespannt wer den ersten
punkt ein pferd weil habe ich geburtstag
also ok ich muss dazu sagen
[Musik]
jetzt abgesagt die dummen ist egal wir
kommen wieder wir wollen uns wieder
willkommen zu welchem frage was hatte
ich früher für ein haustier scheiße ja
komm jetzt mal was los da muss an dieser
stelle sagen ich hatte kannst du hast
mir erzählt dass du ein haustier hatte
ich hatte früher definitiv kein ja
vielleicht mal ein paar spinnen
eingebuchtet in st
nein ich hatte kein haus die frühe und
spaß
sorry aber ich war schneller willkommen
zur nächsten frage und zwar wie viele
paar schuhe habe ich nur das weiße kleid
ich habe die cd selbst hier eingeräumt
die noch dazu hat er auch noch andere 14
so richtig warum aber werden sich ich
wusste es möglich ist richtig und ist
richtig
das wird der erste fall war dann schnell
das schneiden sie das sind eigentlich
fragen die weiß nicht was
dazu noch etwas leicht und bally du
eigentlich auch wissen müssen bis bereit
wie kann man hier nehmen auf welchem
zwei kontinenten wenn nicht schon
gewesen wäre in europa und was noch im
urlaub
ich bin mir unsicher wir haben retter
bis jetzt schon etwas sagen weil sonst
ist der andere vielleicht schneller ich
weiß nicht welcher teil auch er sagt
jetzt jemand das fahrzeug
das ist jetzt schon wieder hier und er
hat alte schlepper aus
das habe ich als erstes sagt okay das
stimmt dann lassen wir das hier mal 1
eingestiegen obwohl europa wird es dann
3 1 jetzt bin ich mal gespannt mit wie
vielen jahren habe ich angefangen
fußball zu spielen
ich habe mein ziel mit 1 peters stimmung
war ich habe mir hier aufgeschrieben
vier aber du kannst vielleicht wenn ich
das gesagt habe dann kriegst du einen
punkt okay also wie steht's 2 203 2
steht was ist die lieblingsfarbe von
meiner oma
dein gesicht sollte ein gesicht und du
sollst du elektroschock in deutschland
ist noch was irgendwas vermisst von alex
kennen oder nicht hängt natürlich wird
wieder für ungewisse ich habe es hier
aufgeschrieben
so kommen wir zur nächsten frage wie oft
war ich schon im krankenhaus also halt
übernachten weil ich in jos schlimmen
2000 gab einmal weil du gesagt hast du
würdest erst einmal also dass wir also
jetzt nicht eine nacht hast oder
übernachtet sondern diese mehreren recht
als operiert wurde
du hast und meint das wäre es eigentlich
stimme hast du schon gehabt hatte was
mir hat einmal also auf jeden fall
zweimal weißes hemd aber prozent risse
drittes mal weißt du wenn du bist die
ganze zeit aus dem bild und muss man
einmal er sagt jetzt dreimal
ich war echt dreimal im krankenhaus
einmal wurde ich einmal wegen einer
gehirnerschütterung das sollte mal wurde
ich operiert und das dritte mal hat sich
weiter auch nie was in zündet im juni
dass endlich das stimmt sagt das ist ja
jetzt nichts schlimmes aber früh gehört
komplett zur nächsten frage ich habe
zwei cousinen und von der 1
die hat zwei namen und was ist ihr
zweiter vorname alter dann er ja ich
muss jetzt eben was schwer zu ja es ist
aber nur raten unter den namen ja ich
brauche das nicht
[Musik]
ja es ist so lustig ist ein see vorbei
mehr eine frage habe ich nicht okay
kommen wir zur letzten frage wer ist
mein lieblings fußballer messi messen
juni mit irgendwas noch seine
verteidigung oder sony
das muss jetzt die orange essen da ich
hol dir jetzt in diese stimme ist
bestimmt eine die an die andere seite
einmal kurz man ihm halten wir fest
natürlich besser sei daher die umwelt
sich nochmal vorzunehmen einmal auf
dieser höhe haben und jetzt kurz mal
kürzeren kamera hätte projekt
das
gut
so wird es richtig wenn nämlich
eigentlich ab und wollten wissen was die
farbe lipinski hättest du deinen einigen
seiner besten freunde von gut weil meine
beste freue er sich auch zu dem lokal
wie sofort an diallo die auch bin ich
habe von der oma von meiner besten haben
bei demenz leiden so ich habe versucht
mit dem die sich sowas dem namen wahr
ist ist sie saß hier so siebels in sich
hinein reicht ja heute das warten im
video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen die
orientierung auf jeden fall hinten da
nach oben
ich hoffe aber juli verweisen youtube
channel bei instagram auf maries kanal
und ist im open finalisten account und
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder wollen
gibt es neues video im glauben hoch